but first i'm joined by business
secretary quasi quatting good morning
secretary of state
um let's start with those numbers um we
now know that the typical household is
going to have to pay 700 pounds more
each year for their heating while they
take home 500 pounds less mr sumat sunak
has promised 350 pounds back the
majority of which is alone by the way
now all that before seven percent
inflation kicks in you're an economic
historian so we all know you can add up
um where's the missing 850 quid per
household going to come from so we've
said very clearly uh that uh this is a
difficult
uh place to be
uh we know that this is a global
challenge because
you've seen a quadrupling four times
increase in gas prices and i was very
clear at the beginning of the winter in
september
that the price cap
would protect people it has protected
people you're right to say there's been
an increase
in the price cap but i was very pleased
to see that the chance for the exchequer
last week came up with the measure uh
the set of measures that you've
described now the 200 pounds i think is
a real help and it's not just the 200
pounds it's 150 off uh council tax but
there are other measures as well there's
the warm home discount uh which has been
increased and is now applying not only
to two million people but to three
million people 100 so there is 150
pounds it all adds up
but you're quite right to save 850
your average typical household is going
to find themselves
what 50 to 100 pounds short every month
it's going to be a very difficult time
and i've maintained that uh throughout
the last few months that's why we've got
the price cap we're trying to shield
people from global price increases it's
not something that we can do up 100
percent
uh but i think the ma the package of
measures that the chancellor announced
last week
were impressive and uh extensive as well
well i don't think when you say
impressive it's not that impressive to
the average household who'd be told
it's difficult i mean
forgive me uh that people are gonna be
saying is that all you've got it's going
to be difficult well look i think that
people understand that this is a global
issue
so gas prices have gone up four times
uh and clearly what's happened is that
the price the retail price that hasn't
gone up four pounds and that's because
four times then that's because
uh of the energy price cap we're the
only uh country in europe that has a
price cap that's shielding uh consumers
and
uh we will continue to do so yeah but
since you've brought it up in france i
think that the rise is four percent i
mean
it's 54 percent here i mean what have
the french got that we don't have so the
first maybe the french are exposed to um
higher prices they've also managed to
scare
a lot of um people who are trying to
invest in france we've got the highest
in with investment uh of any of any
country in europe that's relevant trevor
to to this whole uh equation that we're
we're
uh securing uh jobs hundreds of
thousands of jobs you've got a very very
low unemployment rate but you're right
to say that the cost of uh living is an
issue look um
let's talk about the actual difficulties
that people are going to face um how is
this uh thing with the uh
the loans on energy going to work
what happens if um i
in two years time when you start you're
supposed to start paying it back 40 quid
a year uh i set up my own home for the
first time in two years because i'm a
first year student or i've been
separated from my spouse does that mean
i'll still be paying the 40 pounds
uplift but i won't have benefited from
the um
from from the loan will i no so you'll
get people who get uh the upfront uh
loan will be paying it over five years
um and that's uh that's how it's going
to be repaid over five years uh it's a
smoothie but what if i
my question really that's what
somebody's going to be yeah you will be
paying um your energy prices according
to the according to the price cap
according to what the price cap will be
at that but would you but would you
still be paying the 40 pounds a month
a yeah sorry bank button 40 pounds a
year would you be paying that back so
even if you hadn't had it so as i said
you'll be paying according to the price
cap according to what your supplier um
but that's a different kind of thing
it's important that's an answer to a
different question if if i haven't had
the benefit
of the uh
of the 200 pounds will i subsequently
still be expected to pay 40 pounds extra
on my bills what i'm trying to say is
that the way in which the money is
recouped on the may be reflected in the
price cap and my department is working
with treasury to work out the exact
process how that money is uh recruit but
that's the principle so what you're
going to try and do is
when you get to that point fix it but
you haven't really closed the the
principle has been established that
where um the treasury's going to give
200 pounds and then the money will be
recouped over five years
but of course i can't predict you i
can't tell you what this what the price
will be in five years time but it will
be recouped off that all right look
there's there's a there's a separate
point here really which is
it's it's one about fairness really
isn't it
you're going to be treating millionaire
homeowners
in exactly the same way as people who
rent a studio apartment we know that um
the highest
10
highest 10 of income earners
pay about 4 in energy costs the lowest
10 percent pay 13
um
but you're giving them the same amount
of money i don't think that's quite
right in fact actually the the way that
we would have given them the same amount
of money is if we'd adopted the labor uh
policy of uh essentially just removing
the vat that would have given everyone
uh regardless of their income the same
uh amount uh proportion back everybody's
still getting so quick so where where
where we are here and you mentioned it
earlier is that we've of course got the
150 pounds uh discount off the council
tax which relates to cap bands a to d
now you'll appreciate that you know the
highest uh income earners in the country
are not living in a to d properties
generally they're living in uh higher
bands so they're not going to get 150
pounds so it's not right to say uh that
people are getting this oh well well
well let's talk about that council tax
thing because um
the banding is based on historic
property values that's right 1988
which means that people in london who
live in homes worth more than half a
million
are in the same band and will get the
same uh
help as people who live out in the
country in homes worth
less than half of that i.e people in
uh
wealthy people in london homes will get
the same money as poorer people uh in in
the rest of the country how's that
working again that's not quite right i
mean you're quite right to say that the
council tax ref is
refers back to 1991 i think prices but
um
that's a general issue with the council
tax what this uh rebate this discount
does is it targets people at bands a to
d
so
wherever they're living these are not
people living in the most lavish homes
or the most affluent people
in the in their boroughs and i think
they're getting uh reasonable support
it's not uh going to pay for everything
but i think it is a step forward in
trying to
alleviate the pressure that many people
face all right i just want to give you
the chance to clarify because you
mentioned it a moment ago
the chancellor
is not going to consider cutting v80 on
fuel that's off the table well i was
just mentioning the fact that the v80
off uh fuel uh is a
it's a benefit that is quite regressive
actually because rich people will
benefit just as much as people on lower
incomes that's not something which uh
the conservative party or the chancellor
want to do they want to have more
progressive taxes so that people who can
who need the money
are the ones who get it so he's
definitely not going to do it that's up
to the chancellor i
have uh spoken to him and that's not
something that he's considering he had a
very full package last week i was
there in the house
for 70 minutes i listened to it very
carefully i agreed with all of it um and
i think it's a it's a good set of
measures that he's brought in i talked
to your colleague liz trust last week
and i did put it to her that um the cut
in household income equates to about 12
weeks shopping if you uh shop in
waitrose um and i i worked out this week
that it's actually more like 20 weeks if
you shop at aldi um why are you
punishing the poor by forcing them to
choose between heating and eating well
as i've tried to say
all the measures most of the measures of
the transfer announced last week with
regard to energy bills
are very strongly targeted at people
uh on lower incomes we haven't uh talked
yeah but they've already they're losing
lots and lots of money out of this
netflix we haven't we haven't uh talked
about uh the warm home discount i
mentioned that you seem to dismiss that
but i think that's significant i think
that the uh 350 pounds package is
significant and also if you look at the
bigger picture we are the fastest
growing economy in the g7 people uh are
not facing unemployment and you've got
to remember that at the middle of covert
in 2020 people were prophesying that
there'd be millions and millions of
people unemployed and thanks to the
interventions that the chancellor made
uh we we avoided that so i think the
prospects the economical aspects
challenging are are actually promising
as well all right the reason i didn't
mention the warm homes discount is it's
been there for years yeah but it's not
it's it's not new
but but all your there's no result with
the number of people who are going to
benefit from it it's going to increase
50 that's a million more people all
right let's talk about um
this is a politics show and that's so
let's talk about politics so charles
walker one of the prime minister's most
loyal supporters uh is in the observer
this morning saying it's inevitable
that's his word that tory mps will
remove the prime minister from office
if charles walker's saying that um
game's up really isn't it well i don't
know where charles walker's um
where he's coming from i didn't see what
he's seeing i think he's a good uh vice
chairman of the knights too
well you know he's entitled to his view
as i'm entitled to mine he's talking to
his colleagues and i have to say trevor
you know this i mean lots and lots of
people have said things are inevitable
and they never happened uh over the last
few years uh and i just want to wait and
see i'm very focused on delivering uh
the agenda as is the prime minister i
spoke to him uh earlier in the weekend
and we're very focused on making sure
that we have a strong economic recovery
that we've dealt uh with the american
virus and also with
the the covid pandemic that we're
creating jobs we're bringing in
investment into the uk those are the
things we're focused on as well as
dealing with international challenges as
we're seeing in the ukraine and with
russia so that's what we're focused on
charles walker was also elected on the
manifesto that we all were elected on
2019 and i'm sure he's 100 focused on
delivering on that manifesto
so um
uh
as we're on the issue of ukraine are you
one of the people whom the prime
minister has said it is reported this
morning that it will take him a tank
division to drag him out of number 10.
and if you were were you one of the
people who might have said to him
prime minister shouldn't you be worrying
about the tank divisions threatening
ukraine rather than i think he's
worrying about uh the tank division
let's face it did he say that
no i haven't mentioned uh he didn't
mention that at all i had a very uh good
conversation with him we were focusing
on uh jobs we're talking about economic
recovery uh we did mention
uh ukraine but i don't recognize uh the
language that's been reported
yeah but we're talking about this and um
in a way it's all of mr uh johnson's own
doing isn't it isn't it i mean uh mr
cynic and mr javid have both said this
week that they would not have used the
words
that he used about sakir stama let's um
start this bit by just asking me asking
you would you have used those words i
think it's entirely legitimate would you
have to use those oh you wouldn't use
those it depends what the context was i
mean in that context would you have used
words
in that context i think it was perfectly
reasonable to mention the fact uh that
zakir had apologized sakir himself
apologized on behalf of the uh of the
organization that he led about the fact
that they failed uh to prosecute uh
jimmy seville so the fact that he
apologized suggests that he does at some
level bear some responsibility now i
don't appreciate himself the day after
he said that's not what i meant
are you sure you want to say that you
would have used those no what i'm trying
to say is that it's about leadership
it's about accountability secure
apologized and so that was something
that was absolutely in scope now i'm not
saying that he had a personal blame he
didn't uh and we've been very clear
about that and the prime minister
clarified that position as well but i
think in the in the cup and thrust of uh
debate uh when people are talking about
leadership and accountability um
bringing up something that serbia
himself apologized for uh
seems reasonable would it have been good
leadership if uh he had taken the advice
of his
now former head of policy manira murder
and apologized for giving the impression
which i have to confess pretty much
everybody else in the country took that
he was talking about sakir himself i
think he clarified uh what he said but
he was very clear that uh
did not have a personal responsibility
was not his fault personally should he
but zakir did apologize on behalf of the
organization that he led and that's what
leadership should the prime minister
have apologized i think the prime
minister was absolutely right to clarify
uh his position manila mirza has her
position and subsequently
left left her role
steve barkley
he's now the prime minister's new chief
of staff
he's already a minister
he's got his constituency um
one's tempted to ask you know if he's
got enough time now to be chief yourself
what have you been doing with all this
spare time up until now i think what
steve's doing i mean it's a great
appointment by the way i've worked with
steve in government for four years now
and he's one of the most honest most
rigorous
uh most collegiate ministers we have and
i think it's absolutely right that we
should try and get the cabinet office
and number 10 uh working more cohesively
together and that's what sue gray said
in her report she said that there were
leadership structures that weren't that
were opaque uh that was it was very
difficult to see where the
accountability was
and by appointing uh steve i think the
prime minister is recognizing that and
he's trying to combine
uh the number 10 operation with that of
the cabinet office and as you know steve
is
head of the cabinet office in his role
as uh cdl chancellor the duchy of
lancaster um secretary i'm i'm looking
back over you know what we what we've
discussed and what you're saying to me
is charles walker
well who knows what
what he's on when he says this this
stuff about the the prime minister
having to go uh you don't agree with mr
sunek and to javid that prime minister
they shouldn't have used those words
you don't think he should uh apologize
um
the prime minister's friend donald trump
once said that he could stand in the
middle of fifth avenue shoot somebody
and he wouldn't lose voters what does
boris johnson have to do for you to call
time it's pretty much what donald trump
said was completely a responsibility
it's not comparable you're you're mixing
uh these things up which they shouldn't
they're very different prime minister's
accountable uh with the ministerial code
he's also ultimately accountable to the
electorate and people forget this but he
won a majority as the leader of the
party of 80. uh he has a mandate for the
rest of his parliament and my job as a
minister in the government is to make
sure that we deliver on that mandate and
work hard for leveling up work hard to
increase jobs to increase investment
in this economy and that's largely what
is happening
at the moment and i'm very very focused
on on for the next two years delivering
on that agenda and you absolutely do not
agree with the
stance which is apparently being taken
by your colleague mr sunak who
is essentially distancing himself from
what the prime minister's been saying
this week i was with rishi sanak in the
house of commons for nearly an hour and
a half last week
and he unveiled a really good set of
measures to help people no but i'm
talking about what he said about the
prime minister so why i'm mentioning
that is that we're working together
we're 100
uh behind the prime minister and we want
to deliver
on uh the mandate that we were elected
on successfully in 2019
secretary state thank you very much
indeed for your time this morning